hi my name is Maggie McGrath I'm the
editor of Forbes Women and today I'm
here to tell you about our 16th annual
power women ranking it's our list of the
world's 100 most powerful women across
business media entertainment technology
finance and politics to report out our
list of the world's most powerful women
the Forbes women team combs through all
the lists that already exist here at
Forbes the Forbes 400 the world's
billionaires lists self-made women we
have 13 billion airs on this year's list
in fact we also look at the celeb 100
our list of the world's highest-paid
entertainers some of those women like
Taylor Swift and Rihanna have made our
power women list because they influence
fans around the globe through their
music their social media and in the case
of Rihanna with fenty their business
newcomers in the media and entertainment
space also include Reese Witherspoon and
Ava Duvernay
both women have production companies and
are shaping the way Americans consume
stories particularly stories about
underrepresented communities about and
by underrepresented communities which is
hugely important as we head into 2020 in
prior years when we've done the world's
most powerful women list we've had
leaders in South America make the cover
of Forbes magazine political unrest in
the region has led to a drop-off of
nearly all of those figures but in
business this year there's been a
resurgence we have on this year's list
making her debut Paula Santilli she is
the head of PepsiCo Latin America a
seven point four billion dollar business
and we also have the new CFO of
Petrobras one of the world's largest oil
companies both of these women were
appointed their positions in the spring
and make their debut on the list this
year and give Latin America a resurgence
on our power women list in Africa we
looked at heads of states across every
country in the continent what's hard is
those GDPs don't measure up to some of
the other GDPs in the world so these
women who also aren't always popularly
elected I have a little bit of a harder
time making the list we have the head of
Ethiopia on this year's list but a
number of other ministers of tourism and
finance and economy who are on our women
to watch list which is a separate list
that we have as a web only piece this
year coming in at number one for the
ninth year in a row is German Chancellor
Angela Merkel
she runs what is Europe's largest GDP
largest economy she has a huge impact on
the region and on the world she sits on
the European Council which appoints
women like Christine Lagarde who is
number two on this year's list she runs
the European Central Bank was appointed
to this position just this year after
running the International Monetary Fund
for a number of years and Merkel also
helps appoint women like ursula von der
Leyen she is the new president of the
European Commission that ye use
legislative arm and with that power
affects legislation that hits 700
million people and brings her to number
four on the list the highest ranking
American woman is Nancy Pelosi she's
number three on the list and the US
Speaker of the House for the second time
in recent history she served as Speaker
from 2007 to 2011 and was on the
powerless back then dropped off after
she fell out of power after the
Democrats fell out of power but she is
back on the list and she is second in
line for the presidency is the
highest-ranking elected woman in the
United States right now and leading
impeachment proceedings against the
president so one could say that her
influence at this moment in time is
higher than it's ever been before so
it's a really strong return to the list
for Speaker Pelosi elsewhere in the top
10 we have melinda gates who is the
chair of the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation and affecting a huge amounts
of philanthropy with their work abroad
and in the u.s. focusing on girls
education and health and wellness some
notable movements include Queen
Elizabeth I talked to scholars and
economists about whether or not the
queen is actually powerful and opinions
range let me tell you last year the
Queen was number 23 on the list this
year she's number 40 I think this is
reflected by dint of her giving some of
her patron ages and charities to her
sons and her daughters-in-law we still
think the Queen is a historic figure in
the world and in politics and a very
important lady but as she is 93 it does
appear like she's ready to transition
some of her powers to the king in
Waiting Prince Charles another notable
newcomer this year is Greta Sundberg
the Swedish climate change activists who
was just 16 spoke at the UN General
Assembly this year and sparked millions
of people to pour into the streets to
protest against in action on climate
change she's number 100 on this year's
list our methodology does prioritize
assets under management company market
cap revenue country's GDP Greta has none
of these things but what she does have
is social media and influence she had
more news clips about her than almost
any other woman on the list
other than Angela Merkel and Nancy
Pelosi so she is a newcomer and showing
how power can go beyond just money and
market cap 2017 was the year of me too
and times up and 2018 seemed to me the
year of fallout from that a lot of
grappling with the revelations that had
occurred the year before 2019 from my
reporting seems to be the year of action
I'll be at slow action maybe shifts is
the better word but you have the
appointment of women like Christine
Lagarde and Ursula von der Leyen you see
funds like all raised trying to get more
money in the hands of female
entrepreneurs change is happening it's
happening slowly but the women on the
power list are using their power to lift
up the next generation and to create
gender parity for all
[Music]
you